so in this video I'm going to talk about
pain now we talked in the last video
about the symptom is not the problem we
want to pull a string and the problem in
medicine is we they treat the symptom in
the pain I'm going to show you a little
technique just for the fun of it about
what I do to get rid of 99% of all the
pain that people have and so it's very
it's very simple and I'm just going to
demonstrate it right now so you have you
have pain down this arm right down this
way right here okay okay so first thing
we're to do is we're and you can do this
to your friends and family or yourself
10 being very severe zero being no pain
how would you rate it right now five so
we want to get a number because we're
gonna ask her before and after so it
works on the principle of opposites the
way to fix any part of the body is work
on the opposite side so I'm going to
just take this side
and I'm gonna just rub rub the opposite
side okay now it could be coming down
from the neck too but all you have to do
is rub this thing wherever it hurts on
the right side or left side you rub the
opposite side right through in there and
you're just getting circulation right
through that area okay and it goes does
it go all the way down your hand on the
other side it goes to here okay so we're
gonna rub down here okay right down here
okay so now that was there five what's
the number now so what would you how
would you give me a number two okay did
you see how fast that was did it shift
in location where did it go so she
doesn't really feel the shooting you see
how fast that worked this stuff is like
pure magic because all you do is you
work on the mirror image side but if she
told me let's say it moved to right this
area right here then I would just rub
rub this area right here so we want to
rub the
opposite side okay now you also said you
had some leg pain too right well it's
down in my shoulder oh so it shifted
okay so can you just kind of stand up
turn this way all the way here so it's
right here right here okay so then we're
just gonna rub this area right through
here on the opposite don't rub the side
that hurts that's what everyone else
does it's gonna take too long okay what
does this one feel like now it's gone
it's gone so go ahead and turn around
right here and have a seat so you can do
this with any part of the body let's say
she had a tooth problem after she had a
tooth extracted and still hurts
finding the opposite tooth on the
opposite side and press on the gum area
right here and it'll just massage a
little bit and that pain will go away
and the way this works is this this is
the principle your body avoids pain
right your body doesn't like pain your
brain doesn't like pain you probably
don't like pain for some reason people
don't like pain so when you have an
injury or a pain what happens you lose
the connection to that part of the body
whether it's in chronic knee injury or
foot injury or whatever so if you lose
the communication lines or the
connection you lose the ability for your
own body to heal itself so all we're
doing is we're working on the opposite
side simply because the opposite nerves
are actually connected the left and
right side the body are connected on
circuits so when you do this side right
here you're actually sending signals up
to her brain to heal the opposite side
and it could happen like that so that's
one thing that I want to show you and
then so you can take this any part of
the body so left and right and let's say
it hurts right here you can work on the
back if it hurts on the back you can
work on the front so try this at home
check it out and see how you like it